what's going on there reject nation we
are gonna check out witcher episode five
of season one today but before we go
into that john why don't you go ahead
and tell us about today's video sponsor
oh sorry man i know we're supposed to
shout out magic spoon today i just
couldn't help myself dude you know i
can't have dairy that's why i asked to
be on top of the shadow oh okay man i
got this magic spoon johnson's trying to
eat healthier and cut down on his carb
and sugar intake yeah man luckily magic
spoon has a bunch of delicious flavors
each with zero grams of sugar 14 grams
of protein and only four net carbs per
serving oh wow it's actually not bad how
many calories only 140 per serving but
they're gluten and soy free and keto
friendly
what flavor is that i like to mix the
peanut butter and the cocoa flavors to
create like a peanut butter cup we got
so many great flavors like cookies and
cream maple waffle blueberry frosted
fruity whatever you want man it's like
the cereal we grew up on but it's
actually nutritious oh man
when you use our link in the description
box
and the pink comment you can enter our
promo code at checkout and save five
dollars on your order even a variety
pack that i wish i could taste and they
have a 100 percent happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it you can get your
money back no questions asked
why just let me have like one little
bite give me the link in the description
box dude
one little problem you could gross
chewing your mouth closed
[Music]
is that a piece of turkey
leftovers
oh
[Music]
it's a little of everything
this guy reminds me of myself
in the morning i use a special cleansing
cream
they're different to other dopplers
they're not good natured or helpful are
you and yet you are here for our help do
you not have errand boys where you come
from they lack to your valuable set of
skills don't worry
it's not silver
hand the camera down people come on
seriously you cowards
[Laughter]
we'd planned on wearing this one for a
while
but we are flexible
[Laughter]
cool it's like self-plastic surgery yeah
cool shape shifter twist doppelganger
self-made that's neat
run
why what's the point
everything you've ever done
ever dreamed is in our head now you
can't change the world this way only one
of us will be alive to find out why'd
you make him run yeah you gotta have
that little extra ounce of adrenaline
you have to bring me the girl alive
so many rules
fine
but it'll cost you
children are our favorite
of course they are
as you can see passion is not a trouble
our issue
my
issue is of a mechanical nature can't
get it up
fancy magic viagra the spell should take
effect quickly and will endure until
your lady utters a hand-picked magic
word anything come to mind
conquered
you arrived at that rather quickly
i'm good it is conquered
[Music]
he is bober
perhaps you are not aware of the rules
here if you are casting spells i need to
collect what's due to the kingdom oh god
no casting without proper taxing
haveland
that's right we shall take them on yeah
she already knows the inner workings
the sword of destiny has two edges you
must make the choice
you can stay
or you can continue on your search
what do you want to do just stay for a
little bit man learn the ways of the
brachial on forest get some leaves in
your hair
i'm looking for a joke for a gin a g
like a genie
the floaty fellas with the the bad
tempers in the band magics that kind of
genie yes it'll draw me wishes it's in
this lake somewhere and i can't [ __ ]
sleep
[Music]
oh we are so having this conversation
come on carol tell me be honest
how's my singing
[Laughter]
it's like ordering a pie and finding it
has no filling
burn
you
need a nap
i mean are you the wizard seal
the gin do you mind if i
ask you take back that bit about my
fillingless pie take it back and then
you can have your ginny jin jin let go
no no let's go
oh boy
a bit of an anti-climax
oh no
i have breathy and as of this day i am
thy lord
yes
come on you always say you want nothing
from life so how was i supposed to know
you wanted three wishes all to yourself
just what's up well here's your piece
oh dude what is your deal
oh
[Music]
oh god that's really hit your vocal
cords
a gin in a bottle it's like a fairy tale
without the happy ending can you help
him
[Music]
whoa
oh oh no
these injuries are the magical nature i
can help with the pain but it's a bit
like putting self on a tumor
oh jesus action isn't halted as soon as
possible that damage might be
irreversible
no your money maker
and the longer he goes untreated the
more likely it is to spread
he could die oh [ __ ] girl
yeah we won't let that happen
hang in there buddy
you'll have to take him to another town
there isn't a mage here
go find your cell phone you had a first
time boys
yeah [ __ ] the damn timeless
hey man i don't know she's she's been
around for a long time the mayor himself
has made the catch and has imprisoned
the mage
in his house that wasn't so [ __ ] hard
was it
be careful
the mage is powerful and malicious
and quite cunning
i'll go find him yeah
he'll be everything you could never be
without you which is the rub you only
want me to do well so long as you had
your hand in it how did we get this way
i gave you all i could give there's so
much animosity yeah
everything
you may go rectress
i have business to attend to
well that hurts
she helped make you who you are yeah
she looked out for you a lot
that was also pretty harsh
how'd she get so tough
how's your guests are good this is
urgent i don't make their own but money
opens all doors
a plus
that is a boss move
is there a mage that lives here
the apple juice
she wants some
and she always gets what she wants i
don't understand does he want me to get
the apple juice
so she's just like controlling the whole
thing yeah
she's around
oh my wow
well this is gonna be hard to show on
youtube
a big
flesh-colored block
it is universe
brought you apple juice
[Laughter]
you're
a mutant
a witcher
geralt of riviera
hey
you guys meet
fix it
and i'll pay you whatever the price
sweet
oh maybe you can make a wish
get your baby back
fishing for a gin seems an extreme
measure drama what a fascinating way for
the hey classic shot
well hey now
about that payment
judging by your wrists and your wits
your childhood was very happy but eratus
affects you up nicely
what was your ailment before
clubbed foot
split ends
tell me are there women who find this
coarseness charming
i think you find it a little sharp
and to pretend you're after a gin to
cure insomnia
ooh
deep cut
once i've paid for your kind services
it'll be none of your concern
fortunately for you
i've determined your company and
conversation payment enough
hey now i'm not easily satisfied
is that the wizard seal yeah
i'll be taking skin now if you wake him
before he's healed the spell won't take
of course
you want the gin
but the m4 is broken
the gen's already long gone
do go on
tell me how stuff works
gooseberries
tough to get in your head
oh no
oh man
vake
ah
where are we
at this spa
where do you think we are
the sentence will be passed by the very
council members you attacked
no [ __ ]
i admit i could have better prepared you
for jennifer
you're in love with her
and i think perhaps
you may understand me who wouldn't be in
love with her damn yeah
oh where am i
um
oh
what the hell
you're the one with the wishes
what
i wish very badly to leave this place
forever
[Music]
oh damn why did yarn attack him then i
don't know
unless geralt made those wishes
internally i mean jar in the chin
the jar
shows up
puts you ask here in his little grogu
holder it's perfect she wants to become
more powerful
but she'll die
well let's pray for her on our way out
of town
he cares
she saved your life yesterday i can't
let her die oh
yeah buddy
this isn't weakening
the body expressed his last wish but
it's
it's getting stronger
oh god
you're the king's master
yeah
becoming the vessel for the tin will
have you lose control not
can't you see what this is doing to you
release the genes
i'll give you my last wish
your heroic protector
noble dog permitting my success so long
as you command commandeer yourself
[ __ ]
oh my god
what did you wish
oh
you ain't never had a friend like me
so will smith's pops out
she could not have survived
oh what would white girl go in there
doesn't make any sense geralt saved her
he
why because she was magnificent she's
[ __ ] hot as hell was it
you were there you saw it
i saw how powerful and commanding she
was
she's got great personality she's
independent for so many reasons why
wouldn't you simper
and jinns are only dark creatures when
they're held captive how can you be so
sure
when did you last feel happy when you
felt trapped
oh
you're gonna have a new tale to tell i'm
gonna write you
the best song
so that everyone remembers who you are
oh no you're
so waiting for that
carol oh no no it's always gonna oh my
god this is so embarrassing
[Music]
how much does it ask to see henry cavill
naked hey seriously come on
everyone on game of thrones did it
my plan were
it was my plan it was all to get in your
pants
i've been very lonely and it's why i
can't sleep
what did you wish for
that we would do it
[Laughter]
she's asleep
[Music]
oh it's the doppler
to the intention testing
the burden of power can be painful the
power's power
your destiny is
in your own hands and no one else's
farewell
special one
you're not the look so like
that's right
i feel like you fit right in with all
these women yeah
is that over
oh
you really feel when the episodes are
five minutes shorter yeah right
damn
so much sexuality
making the editing fun on this one
because the youtube
let's inventive only use that footage
it was a hell of an episode absolutely
that was awesome they did it
tosser groin junior witcher
oh valley of milan
oh yeah
this is very yeah this was a very sexy
episode everyone was getting it on at
some point in this episode yeah i was
thinking of um
freaking
spartacus
i think that's the show yeah the
showtime series
especially when they had like the origin
thing going on but that was
that was way more like a ramped up and
kinetic and
raw this was like very dead that scene
was very dreamlike and ethereal they
were under
an enchantment yes pleasant
frolicking and floating
yeah
like cherubs yeah yeah
admittedly i'm like this is the first
time they're meeting pay attention
stop looking at the background it's a
space jam a new legacy all over again
yes except for the way more convincing
background cast i mean they all looked
like they were really involved in that
i'm just so distracted i was like is
that one girl on wires they've been
holding her up a whole lot have they
trying to paint trying to pay attention
what they're saying
yeah man that was uh that was good but i
thought i i wonder what the casting
process was like with
um having henry cavill an
actress who plays jennifer because
you firs for something like this i feel
like you'd want to test out what their
chemistry is like and
they do fortunately have really good
chemistry yes they do they exude sexual
chemistry
i like i love the banter and the
the little gesture ingesting that they
have yeah when they are you know
building up that sexual tension like
when they're in the bathtub that's a
great scene and that's a really well
captured scene yeah it was basically
them just saying cut through the
[ __ ] yeah no more [ __ ]
stop like because they both
with both their characters it's kind of
like the similarities that i've noticed
with them is when they're in
conversation they're usually the ones
saying
stop bullshitting me yeah
yeah absolutely that was what they were
doing to both of you both of each other
at that same time yeah and they both
have the element of some kind of
mystical magical ability and so there's
also that level of like you know they i
feel like they're used to being trump
cards in a lot of different rooms and
now they're kind of you know more
ambiguous to each other because of their
you know
different but similar skill sets yeah we
don't learn much about when we don't
know much about geralt's past
like they keep him mysterious
and
like we know we have a much better
insight into jennifer's past
just as the condition she was born with
and knowing what her actual lineage is
it's so
it makes sense to me how her character
has evolved into this point of
just wanting all the power because she
was robbed of everything her whole life
and she had this potential within her
that was sort of
concealed and pushed away because of her
was she like part elf right
yeah is that what it was yeah and so
that's why she's so good at them
that that also is what lends credence to
why she's so good at
the magic so like when she started
getting a hold of it she started
becoming really fast at it yeah
and yeah i mean just her portal
abilities is so much faster now yeah
so
yeah um
like watching just how far she's willing
to go and this this level you get this
sense that they understand each other
because this is the first time they
alluded to childhood with geralt
when they talked about how um you know
like i was born of the magic that
mages have made is that what they were
saying yeah it's a lot of dialogue to
keep up with but i was basically he was
born of magic and he's like yeah it led
to a magical childhood
clearly it wasn't a great job
thanks for that
but
obviously geralt is someone who is more
sympathetic to people's
um you know plights more than he likes
to let on so the more he can understand
you know what's really going on he
becomes sympathetic towards that he
always seems like he's got the tough
exterior and the dude who doesn't give a
[ __ ]
but then just as we saw in the last
episode with the hedgehog knight
or or even with uh jasper jasper jessica
jazz gear or yeah yes yes gear yeah
let's keep calling them bard
even when you ask here in this episode
you know like i loved how we just like
went all out to help him yeah
everything's so driven up the wall by
his incessant bantery and he was really
he he was really troubled by the fact of
what he asked your last words that he
received from gerald might have been he
was really concerned about that
and then when he goes to save him when
he goes to retrieve him again yeah at
the end when they're when they're
walking away before um geralt goes in
there to help out jennifer
it's like don't get ahead of yourself i
barely care yeah yeah yeah what's up
this front when he really does give a
[ __ ] he really likes them a lot and uh
it's nice seeing that they're the they
do a great job at illustrating how he
cares through his actions more than
anything else absolutely and it's and
and sometimes they make it more in the
forefront but more often than not you
just gotta pay attention and you're like
no this guy really cares a lot yeah
so and this was probably the most overt
heroic moment where they have a
character like yaski or to
be the meta narrative commentary to be
like this is when you decide to go full
hero right now
it was it was great i was really into it
man and i loved the chemistry and it was
a very visual and i love that like the
crescendo of how emotional
jennifer became and geralt like this is
the most emotional we've seen geralt
become yeah yeah when he busts in and
he's really like i'm trying to help you
like please let me help you and and yeah
it struck me in those moments because
we're so used to seeing some impressive
like i feel like there have been a lot
of crescendos with geralt that are very
physical and action oriented and he's
like you know
doing these crazy sword fights that
henry cavill really seems like he
learned how to do and this one it was
nice to have this sort of just battle of
wills and circumstances and you know
having this sort of invisible force and
even the way the film style changed a
bit to resemble just more of an exorcism
type movie like i thought of samuraimy
just because of all the really raked
angles and the extreme lights and stuff
but uh yeah it's like it was cool
because it has a very satisfying quality
as an episode because you get a lot of
geralts and yes gear and then you get
this like you know kind of union that
we've probably all been wanting to see
for a long time with geralt and jennifer
and they made a lot out of both of those
things and it's funny because like
at the outset it's kind of like a silly
circumstance like i just because yes you
wouldn't shut up now or in this
dire situation but a lot comes out of it
and and
in the anthology kind of style of the
show i think this was a really kind of
nice
change of
like it's it's got all the things that
like a witcher episode ought to have
arguably but this was kind of like a
nice dip into the supernatural i feel
like
why do you why do you keep using the
term anthology because i feel like this
is extremely serial it is but like well
because these were taken from like
collections of short stories that are
like all in the same world and all
involve characters that recur and
overlap from my understanding and it's
like
these are all connected and it is very
serial especially with like siri for
example so that's
zero series uh whereas like geralt's
adventures are a little more you know
just kind of like he's
you know tackling another
uh political situation or tackling
another monster or something like that
so like there there are there are a lot
of elements of both but there's
something that feels kind of like one
big
world where we don't necessarily have to
go linearly through everything and i'm
never going to be bummed out when it's
not a linear or a serial part of the
story no i get what you're saying yeah
yeah
well i mean because to me this felt like
one of the most
intertwined and connected yeah because
they brought
more more than the last four were were
really started feeling like it was
coming together in episode four
because
nilfgaard yes is where sarah as
no no
that's
siri because her name i think is cirilla
cirilla yeah damn goddamn
okay i need a board and some yards
yes okay
because yeah even with that storyline
you had mouse cat come back
in in this episode
and then
they they brought it back to you have to
go find geralt's which seems like
there's a subject that's kind of been
dropped in her storyline yeah and
they're they're in the future
or like they're
or over there everyone's in the past and
word they're
90 years ago
geralt's 30 years ago
except for when they overlap and series
in the present yeah it thinks i mean
siri is definitely the most present
presentation
yeah she's she's the one where where
everyone else is technically the the
past
so
um
uh uh yeah like with this one where you
you had this
this uh this situation with yaskir and
and geralt which are very personal and
then of course
they finally crossed paths geralt and
jennifer
yeah
so that's what i mean this felt like
this really this really came together
and as a as a
and i'm i'm really loving it
it's like really engaging and
i get excited just at the start of each
episode you know because i just it's
like yeah and it's funny because i feel
like
at the end i was really worried at the
from the first episode because i was
like oh man is my brain gonna be playing
exactly
and it's like even though there's a lot
to keep track of and names you gotta
make sure to remember like it doesn't
it's not it's funny like i feel like
this show got compared to the outside a
lot to game of thrones like oh there's
netflix's game of thrones because
everybody wants to fill that void now
they just looked at the surface yeah and
i feel like one thing that ties into
that element of like yeah there are a
lot of places and geographical things
and concepts like you know uh you know
the law of surprise or whatever um
there's something about this show and
this world that feels a lot more zoomed
in than that and it's like even though
yeah you do have kingdoms and you do
have you know uh races of you know
humans and elves it feels still a lot
more zoomed in every time and a lot more
on the ground level than you know the
sweeping it's like they still have the
politics and they still have the
intrigue of that variety but it's not in
the huge like
multiple kingdoms and we're looking in
from every kingdom's perspective you
know like it's
i don't know exactly how to describe it
but i feel like there's something
uniquely special
about yeah kind of how they draw i mean
game of thrones is about the game for
the top throne yeah that's essentially
what the show if you were to boil it
down to what it's the plot is yeah just
people gambling and trying to climb
higher and get to the iron throne we're
here it's a little bit
it's not as uh
clear
it's like what's it going here yeah it's
like what's it like to be the the
fringier characters in a world like this
yeah yeah and i like it a lot it
lends itself to a lot of cool
exploration
and and they just keep adding in new
elements every episode like this episode
they introduced the genie and the ninjas
yeah man
and the the the doppelgangers
doppelgangers yeah
gangers and the ginger and dopplers yeah
i see i like the way they're realized
like the genie feels like a malevolent
demon
and it's not
at all how it's sort of been portrayed
in in in media for years and years and
years
as this like graceful
you know
positive wish fulfillment i mean there
have been things where they have
portrayed it in the way how a lot of
lore actually represents genies but here
you don't even like see an actual it's
just like these shadow figures yeah yeah
smoke just go fleeting by or speeding by
and then the dopplers too you know it's
such a cool
we've seen things of like shape shifters
before and
i like that i thought it was going to be
more violent when he does the
transformation because the scene starts
off or he's got like
body parts so i thought it was like a
surgical thing of what they were hinting
at like he's like attaching and growing
or something yeah because he's like
admiring his body and yeah
or maybe keeping them in these jars is
what's the key to being able to
transfigurate yourself but then it just
turned into a nice gotta look at him
really hard yeah
i gotta really connect with his soul
soak in his aura soaking in the wrong
juice my face yeah yeah yeah
i mean uh she's getting out of that
forest i never i didn't find that for
stuff all that interesting
it's weird it's beautiful to look at but
story-wise it wasn't that interesting
yeah it's funny because i i feel like
almost something got
it maybe it didn't but it almost feels
like something got snipped because
you know it's like you're wasting no
time and having fake mouse sack go find
her in their plan their sinister plan
coming to fruition which in some ways
i'm usually happy when they don't waste
too much time with that stuff but at the
same time it seems like we just we just
got here they just accepted you there
are things clearly to learn from this
place and there are ways in which to
expand the world and so now it really
does feel like we stopped here for 10
minutes and right when they decided to
keep and train me uh we're going right
back out again i mean i think it was all
mainly there for whatever
moral conundrums or
walks of destiny and that she's
eventually going to have to come into
conflict with yeah of choice i think it
was mainly there for those lessons this
is the theory i have no idea um it's it
seems like that's what the main takeaway
is about
you know there's gonna come a point in
time
where you're being told what your path
should be but you have to choose your
own path yes
and just like how when fake mouse cat
showed up and said
mouse cat mouse sack
it's okay
mouse cap
the mask
it's all good well
this cup is cheesy
[Laughter]
someone told me there's a rat
on the forest i don't have to really go
through this hey that's that's messed up
man
oh
yes
uh yeah mouse cop yes mouse sack mouth
sack yeah
which he yeah who who are those people
who who are who attack like queen
kalanthi and all that and and are doing
this who who are they do we know who
they are yeah are they i don't
fully recall because they're like
they're essentially the bad guys yeah
you know the evil army yes who brings
just kind of
ill intent wherever they go i can't
remember if they alluded to like this
particular kingdom from the south or the
north or something in in the last
episode like in the first episode like i
feel like
there's probably some bit of context in
there that
alluded to who they were
and uh maybe it didn't get unpacked
quite enough for us plebeians yeah i
also curiosity so is it the the
implication that geralt just wished
yaskir would shut up and that's what
caused this whole thing
because that yes that turned around to
the wishes okay that's what i thought
happened at first yeah but then geralt
was saying [ __ ] and and afterwards
and i thought oh
okay
but what why'd that happen yeah
that's what i thought happened at first
yeah um but he was saying it's the
jarring so
to me i i just rolled with it cause i'm
like i must have misunderstood it
because you're stupid yeah
yeah yeah
it's funny it's it's it's the fine it's
the double-edged sword of giving your
audience a lot of credit because then if
you do miss one or two little pieces of
verbiage or a line of dialogue then you
might be lost yeah so uh good on good on
you guys for making us keep up
a lot nudity in this one this was a
naked episode of the show
sorry guys we will be demonetized if we
show any of that
you don't want to have an age-restricted
reaction i don't want to spend hours on
this video just to go
d monetize yeah
have fun
through the soaks do you guys see the
nips that i can't it's free and better
quality on your own netflix talent
don't blame us
all right guys thank you so much for
being here and um hey subscribe click
that bell thanks to prepper for
anything's down we'll catch you guys
soon